we also uh are keenly aware
of the responsibility that we have for
such a beloved property and that
property is jungle cruise the ride
at the d23 celebration in 2019 dwayne
johnson and emily blunt had
everyone fired up for jungle cruise it's
just
insane and the energy's so incredible
die hard disney fans
know this about the jungle everything
that you see
wants to kill you and can
why is this attraction so beloved by
theme park fans around the world
to answer that we have to go all the way
back to the opening day of disneyland
who come to this happy place welcome
let e.t be your skipper as we travel
upstream to discover how
disney will pay tribute to one of their
o.g attractions
[Music]
this jungle cruise is one of the
original 18 rides at the park
and in arid southern california walt
disney said let's build a tropical rain
forest and they did
using hundreds of tropical plants on
july 17
1955 disneyland made its grand debut
introducing a theme park built on ideas
straight from walt disney's imagination
we're also aware that in 1955 as many of
you know and as many of you may not know
but when the park opened in 1955
walt disney had one baby and that baby
was jungle cruise and he was the very
first jungle cruise skipper
and jungle cruise remains only a handful
of attractions that are still
operating 65 years later a unique
distinction
not lost on the movie's cast this movie
has been years in the making
and from the bottom of my heart i'm so
honored we are all so honored
to bring this rich story uh and movie to
life for all of you guys around the
world
dwayne johnson who's also been a
producer on the movie since it was first
announced in 2015
even spent time with disney's legendary
imagineering team
to learn about the origins of the
attraction well the inspiration for this
particular ride was a series of nature
films disney produced for his television
show
and walt disney literally used
television to build his park
that's right lisa walt envisioned an
attraction that evoked both a cinema
classic
as well as this memorable episode of his
true adventure series
enter the king of beasts the monarch
come to review his subjects
walt had envisioned jungle cruise to
become the main attraction for one of
his park's most
exciting regions disneyland is your land
here age relives fond memories of the
past
and here youth may savor the challenge
and promise of the future
jungle cruise lies deep in the heart of
the adventureland section of disneyland
guests step off the dock and onto the
boats that turn everyone into early 20th
century explorers
as they voyage through exotic rivers
from around the world
with each section of the attraction
featuring life-size animatronics of wild
animals and
if you look to your well screen you'll
see that after the park closes
professional divers perform maintenance
on these mechanical creatures
all clear glamorous job and we're here
to cover it
let's do something that's safe let's go
see some elephants there are no
elephants in the amazon and i don't even
like elephants lady everybody likes
elephants
per usual dwayne johnson is right here
the fan favorite site on the jungle
cruise has got to be this elephant
living their best life
you know disneyland has had more than
its share of visiting foreign
dignitaries they've all been here
a lot of presidents too harry truman
dwight eisenhower john kennedy
heidi klum then there's the story of
king muhammad v
of morocco he was on the jungle cruise
ride walt was showing him everything but
he was
having a little time trying to discern
what was real and what was artificial
well i can understand that it all looks
real well walt loved a good gag
and they got to this waterfall walt
looked at the king and said
almost looks like real water doesn't it
good one walt and wouldn't you know it
years later this type of humor became a
staple of the ride experience
look on the left three two cam
three two cams equals a six pack we put
this disneyland all the time and
i know all things disney super fan
zachary levi might have put it best when
he described
jungle cruise as an eight-minute dad
joke stand-up set
on water the parade of terrible yet
hilarious puns from the skippers are now
a beloved trademark of jungle crews
watch out siberian tiger can jump 12
000 feet when he shoved off
65 years after its first introduction
jungle cruise is now featured in parks
around the world
and it's come to embody the heart and
soul of the disney experience
we are aware how important this ride is
to
everyone in this room generations
everyone around the world
which is why leading up to the movie's
release disney and the film's stars have
gone
out of their way to express their
appreciation for the attraction's legacy
we are so honored to bring this movie to
life on behalf of disney on behalf
of walt disney himself uh and to deliver
to you guys here and everybody around
the world would you like to say this
with me the adventure
of a live lifetime people are like
really losing it with every little word
you say it's just
insane and the energy is so incredible
die hard disney fans you know as emily
was saying that room
not only was it a warm crowd but also it
just helped that i think there was such
great anticipation for jungle cruise for
so
long since it's been it's part of the
fabric of people's
lives and generations for years and
years of all the jungle cruises you can
take in the amazon
this one is undoubtedly the cheapest
but also the most thrilling heads up
coming through
look out well
we've come to the end of our journey but
there's one more reason why disney's
biggest fans are hyped for jungle cruise
of our ride look at here the back side
of
water they've already seen how this
cinematic celebration of the beloved
attraction
will tip its cap to one of the ride's
most iconic jokes
ladies and gentlemen the moment you've
all been waiting for
the backside of water
stays wonder of the world